depende justamente del partido que todo
es nombrado de ie mira porque un
escenario evidentemente es que se una a
su aliado natural que es el partido
conservador likud pero otra alternativa
que no podemos descartar es que los
partidos a la izquierda del mapa
político o en el centro le ofrezcan a la
mina que sea primer ministro el osea
naftalí bennett con el apoyo de todo ese
bloque de esa forma robar ese partido en
una buena intención por supuesto para
que hay una coalición alternativa a
netanyahu osea que hoy tenemos tres
escenarios o bien el likud forma
nuevamente gobierno con benjamin
netanyahu o bien
naftalí bennett y su partido pequeño
lidera una coalición alternativa o bien
vamos a quintas elecciones cuál es la
más opcionada de esas opciones según su
juicio
la primera o sea la primera vez que vine
a mi detallado por más que hoy tiene 59
votos tiene también la posibilidad de
contar con el voto de silencio con la
abstención de un partido árabe que a
cambio de beneficios para la minoría
árabe que es el 20 por ciento de
población
haría silencio y lo dejaría gobernar con
una mayoría mínima entonces naftalí
bennett la persona que estamos nombrando
ahora del partido y amina su sueño es
liderar la derecha y no ser el líder de
una coalición de izquierda ahora varía
el cual es la representación política de
la oposición que es demasiado diversa
además
mira en nuestro sistema se llama un
sistema multipolar que sea extremista
dow o sea en un país que tiene un
sistema parlamentario la gente puede
discutir por uno o dos temas aquí se
discute por lo menos por cinco entonces
lo que ha ocurrido es que el likud tiene
si 30 diputados por ahora pero el resto
de la oposición y los partidos en
general de izquierda se sitúan entre 5 y
7 diputados solamente no más para darte
un ejemplo el partido que fundó el
estado de israel liderado por el
mitológico david ben-gurion el partido
laborista en estas elecciones alcanzó
una cifra positiva para ellos siete
diputados solamente ahora si no puede
formar una coalición de gobierno que
vendría después y de no lograrse una
colisión cuántas veces más podrían mirar
algunas elecciones
en principio indefinida tiene que pasar
90 días después de la decisión de que no
se ha podido lograr por mal gobierno lo
que ocurre es que mira cómo está el mapa
los partidos políticos que apoyan una
visión conservadora lo que sería
prácticamente de derecha suma alrededor
de 80 diputados de 120 lo que pasa que
parte de esos partidos que son
justamente de derecha no quiere a
netanyahu en otras palabras
netanyahu es visto como un tapón que sin
su presencia
probablemente se podría conformar una
coalición rápidamente hay escasez de
contendiente es el frente a netanyahu un
candidato fuerte una persona fuerte que
pueda a lo mejor lograr ser primer
inicio israel
excelente pregunta el problema es que
los israelíes les gusta a los líderes
que tienen mucho carisma y que tienen
conocimientos recuerda que en italia uno
solamente pudo administrar la pandemia
sino que se enfrentó al súper poderoso
obama convenció a parte del mundo que
irán tenía un problema por el tema
nuclear y la economía y sally ha
mejorado durante su cadencia o sea que
es difícil reemplazarlo por más que
muchos consideramos que ahora
necesitamos un líder que logre calmar
las aguas y unir a la población